ah TikTok you will never find a more
wretched hive of scum and villainy
the algorithms there are just so
good at pushing stuff that's… wrong
Today I'm going to debunk a
whole bunch of bad TikToks
it's mostly going to be skincare and I've
responded to some of these before on
TikTok Instagram and YouTube shorts
but in shorter videos I can only fit in
a fraction of what I want to talk about
before it's too long or complex
and the algorithm just ignores it
so in this video I'm going into more detail
let's start with this video bashing CeraVe
santacruzmedicinals: Do you use this
this contains propylparaben
propylparaben is an estrogen-like compound that
is under this class of what we call parabens
women that are trying to get pregnant or
breastfeeding are told to avoid paraben
this is because they're being researched to
disrupt hormone function in a negative way
parabens are in a lot of cosmetic products and I
would not want to rub these onto
my skin my body's largest organ
especially as a man when you
introduce an estrogen-like
compound that can disrupt your testosterone levels
so I don't use this I think this is trash
watching this tiktok kind of made me
feel like I was back in the early 2010s
parabens were one of the first ingredient
classes that got demonized by the natural
beauty movement and then the clean beauty movement
all of this was sparked by a study in 2004 which
found that parabens were in breast cancer tissue
the researcher is called philippa darbre she has
done a lot of research that's
gotten blown out of proportion
so there were a lot of issues with this study
first off they only looked at breast cancer
tissue they didn't compare it with healthy tissue
so parabens are probably in those too
and even if you only found the
parabens in the breast cancer
tissue it doesn't mean that
parabens are causing cancer
it could be that cancer tissue
happens to collect parabens more
it could be some other thing that's introducing
parabens as well as some cancer-causing ingredient
it could be something completely unrelated
because correlation isn't causation
on top of that in this study
the blank samples that didn't
actually have any tissue at all also had parabens
so really all this study showed
is that parabens are used a lot
including in the detergents
used to clean lab equipment
but this study got blown up it was
reported in newspapers in forwarded
emails on Facebook and so this idea that
parabens are bad and they're related to
breast cancer is just in everyone's
minds and it just keeps spreading
all of this paraben-phobia stuff was around
even before I started my blog back in 2011
so hi if you're new here I'm Michelle of lab
muffin beauty science chemistry PhD cosmetic
chemist and person who has been annoyed at
misinformation on the internet for way too long
these days there are barely any
products on the market that have
parabens and he just happened to
pick up one of the ones that does
there's also bunch of specific things he's
saying that are worded very carefully kind
of weasel words and I'm not sure
he's even aware he's doing this
so he says "women that are trying to get pregnant
or breastfeeding are told to avoid parabens"
who is telling them? are they
misinformed? is it just you telling them?
sometimes apparently IVF
clinics and endocrinologists
who are doctors who specialize in hormones
they will say things like this but they don't
necessarily know much about things like
parabens in skincare and their impact
they're often going off things they've come
across on internet sources just like well this guy
one of my friends is actually an endocrinologist
and I chatted with her a couple of weeks ago
she has never been taught anything
about endocrine disruptors in skincare
parabens have been used for over 100 years they're
a super popular preservative that's in everything
that study was in 2004 there's been studies since
and it still hasn't made it onto the medical
syllabus and this is actually a good sign that
parabens probably don't have that big of an impact
he also says "this is because they are being
researched to disrupt hormone
function in a negative way"
and yeah this is clever w
ho was researching this? is it a scientist? is
it just you googling? what were
the findings of this research?
this phrase is a bit like "someone is being sued"
like it is not that hard to sue someone being sued
doesn't really mean much except someone either
doesn't like you or thinks you have deep pockets
he says they're "estrogen-like" but in what way?
the estrogenic activity of parabens
are generally thousands of times
less strong than natural estrogen to begin with
so with propylparaben in the EU there's a body
called the scientific committee on consumer safety
and they look at the safety of different cosmetic
ingredients going into cosmetics in the EU
they actually reviewed all of the evidence on
propylparaben in 2021 because they were going
through a list of potential endocrine disruptors
and looking at all of the data with fresh eyes
they concluded that propylparaben is
safe when used in skin care products
at the previously recommended concentrations
I have another video that breaks
down how these evaluations work
and as part of this evaluation they
looked at what happened if you used
the maximum concentration in 17 different
products and they found that you still get
12 and a half thousand times less than an
amount that they would still consider safe
whenever I talk about this ingredient
safety stuff I always get a lot of
comments asking "don't the amounts add
up if you use more than one product?"
I think people tend to forget that
toxicologists the ones who do these
assessments are also normal people
with normal lives outside of their work
they go home and use products too
they have partners and kids who use
multiple products like this is not a revelation
this is something that is taken
into account in the assessments
now in general big brands like CeraVe they make
pretty much the safest products you can buy
I think a lot of people forget
to do like a reality check when
they accuse giant brands of trying to kill them
these big beauty companies hire tons of scientists
if it was this easy for someone who
has zero science background to just
pick up a product and look at the ingredient list
and just tell that it's unsafe they
wouldn't have released this product
it would just not happen
this sort of stuff goes for approval by lots
of different people including lots
of scientists liability is a thing
on top of that dermatologists
recommend CeraVe all the time
there's just no chance that so many of them are
going around recommending
something obviously harmful
another thing that bothers me is
that he goes on about how the skin
is "the body's largest organ" except
he's holding a face cleanser which
is like your face is about four
percent of your body surface area
I guess it also depends how big your face is but
also skin's main function is to act as a barrier
it would be really bad if
it just absorbs everything
really efficiently just because it's big
it would probably be safer to rub
something all over your skin your
entire giant body organ compared to
rubbing it on like I don't know your
pancreas or something and it'll probably
also be a lot safer to actually reach it
in my original response to this I said
that I really hate this genre of dudes
who don't understand science lecturing people on
science while holding products in supermarkets
a handful of people got really annoyed
at me because reverse sexism or whatever
but if you've been on TikTok for long
enough you'll know that this is a thing
whether it's a thing because more dudes
film supermarket videos because I don't
know they don't actually own skin
care so they can't film at home
or maybe the algorithm is just picking
up more dudes lecturing in supermarkets
because people are more willing to
trust it at face value when it's a man
these videos just blow up and
show up in my feed all the time
women obviously make BS TikToks that blow
up too but they're not this same genre
it usually seems to be like a woman in
her bathroom or her bedroom or she's
holding a product or she's throwing out
products and she is getting really upset
sometimes there's like tears and eyes
sometimes her voice is really shaky
and she's going on about how there's
all these chemicals that she's never
heard of in her products and what are they
doing to us why are they trying to kill us
social media algorithms respond to signals
from people and people have biases there's
plenty of research particularly
in advertising that people tend
to believe technical information when it comes
from a man over when it comes from a woman and
that people accept emotional things like
crying more from a woman than from a man
we live in a society even if you think
you're 100 objective and rational and
not sexist there are tons of people
out there who are so deal with it
Bobby @flavcity: Have you seen the ingredients in
oh God it's Bobby
all right so Bobby is a home cook who
makes videos about what you mostly should
and shouldn't eat and he recently
started on personal care products
there's this trend of people who used to
make food content starting to talk about
how toxic personal care products are and
I think this is because apps that usually
look at food like the EWG app and Yuka
they also have a personal care section
it's just really easy to make scary content
that goes viral using these apps because you
just scan the product and you just
read out what comes up on your phone
Bobby is like a menace scientists
and doctors are constantly debunking
his food content so let's see what he has to say
Bobby: have you seen the ingredients in
personal care products? they're scary
are they Bobby? are they? or do
you just not know these words
Bobby: any time you see the word paraben
put it back especially propylparaben
these are preservatives that prevent mould from
growing in here but they're hormone
disruptors endocrine disruptors
they mimic estrogen in your body and
for the ladies out there they find
more of that in your body because because
it's in your lotions potions and makeup
all right so it's parabens again and the source
he's using here is the ewg Skin Deep database
the ewg is not a scientific source and honestly
any app that judges the safety of products just
based on the ingredients list which has no
information on concentration is pseudoscience
the amount is really important in
safety because the more molecules
of something that you're exposed to
the more chances it has to interact
with whatever part of the body it
has to interact with to cause harm
that's why you might have heard the phrase the
dose makes the poison a lot from toxicologists
the ewg specifically has this really
long history of capitalizing on fear
so for example they used to promote
the idea that vaccines cause autism
that whole thing was based off a study that
was mostly just what did parents remember
the stuff online that explains why the ewg
is bad is mostly about how they approach
food safety but they use the same sort
of principles for evaluating cosmetics
so there was this survey done
by the Society of Toxicology
and they asked 937 members what
they thought about particular ideas
92% of their respondents disagreed that
any level of exposure is unacceptable
for chemicals that have been identified as
carcinogens mutagens or reproductive toxicants
that is pretty much the methodology that
the ewg uses - if it's in there it's bad
they also had 81% rejecting the
notion that the detection of any
level of a chemical in your body
indicates a significant health risk
and yet this is exactly what
the ewg does in their summaries
there's also this article that looked
at the ewg's dirty dozen list which
looks at what foods tend to have
the most pesticide residues and
there's some really good quotes here
but I think the best one is probably
"the methodology used to create the dirty dozen
list does not appear to follow any
established scientific procedures"
and that is pretty much the
same for the Skin Deep database
Bobby: pick up almost any product here fragrance
shaving cream fragrance and body
wash with parfum or fragrance
that's the key word if you see that put it back
because that's the cosmetics
version of natural flavors
but there can be up to 3 000 synthetic
fragrances or perfumes in there they're
proprietary they ain't got to tell you anything
and they're linked to reproductive issues and
they find these fragrances in breast
milk it's scary stuff you don't want it
so yeah finding stuff in your
body is not a sign that is scary
there is a lot of stuff online
about how they don't tell you all
the individual components of
fragrances and therefore it's scary
so there's a pretty obvious reason they
don't tell you because fragrances are
trade secrets just like flavors
just like the Coca-Cola recipe
there's all this consumer research showing
that the first thing people do when
they try a product is they smell it
smell is associated with a lot
of memories and strong emotional
responses and that's why it's in
everything and it's so secretive
it's a large part of what
makes people buy products
for fragrance there's an organization called IFRA
which is the international fragrance association
it's for fragrance producers and they have
rules that their members have to follow
I'll leave the website below
it tells you a lot about them like they
produce 80% of the global volume of fragrance
their rules are based on safety assessments by the
Research Institute of fragrance materials or RIFM
these are scientists who look at fragrance
safety and they publish their safety
assessments in a peer-reviewed journal
there's also a separate independent panel that
reviews what they do including
how they design their experiments
these ifra standards are really
widely recognized in the industry
and by governments and regulators as well
for example if you're registering a
cosmetic product in the EU you can
use an IFRA compliance certificate as
part of your safety dossier there are
even regulations in some countries that
specifically refer to the IFRA standards
so basically if you're buying a product
that's from a reputable brand it should
comply with the ifra standards
and you can probably ask them
alright so let's say Bobby isn't happy with
that he wants to see the full ingredient list
what is he going to do with it?
I mean I wouldn't know what to do with it
again there are no concentrations on this thing
if there are concentrations then I would probably
take it to a toxicologist who
knows stuff about cosmetics
they would probably just tell me to check those
concentrations against whatever IFRA recommends
because they're the people who know the
most about this and do all the research
so you would just end up at the same place
he also goes on about how it could have synthetics
and this how happens a lot when it
comes to cosmetic fear-mongering
we humans have this bias towards
assuming that natural things are
just safer and better it's called appeal to nature
but if you think about it for a
bit it's obviously just not true
nature is constantly trying to kill us
I am from Australia I know this very well
the most toxic substances
known are actually natural
even the most toxic one it
can be safely used it is Botox
and this whole natural bias thing is especially
silly for fragrance because it is really well
established that natural fragrances are full of
allergens which is one of the things he lists here
there are a bunch of allergens you
have to list out in your ingredients
list in certain regions like the EU
and Australia and most of these are
things you find in essential oil
things like linalool and geraniol
maybe he doesn't know this because
he's in the US and yes I do think
this is something that the US should start doing
and with this ewg entry they're
generalizing 3 000 different chemicals here
all of these effects that they've
got they probably come from a small
handful of these three thousand they
might not even be in your fragrance
if they are and you're buying from
a responsible brand then they're
going to be at an amount that
the evidence indicates is safe
plus a lot of essential oils have these
effects as well same as for fragrance
these effects just don't happen at the small
amounts used if the maker is being responsible
one thing I do sometimes worry about
is that some natural brands do use
essential oils and there are limits
on essential oils set by IFRA as well
these brands who are just dumping
essential oils and assuming that
they are safe they could be putting in
way too much so realistically that is
going to be a much bigger problem than
fragrances put in things by big brands
and yes you can avoid all fragrance
things if you want just in case but
it does mean that you're probably
unnecessarily restricting yourself
so he went on about finding stuff in breast milk
again having something in
there doesn't mean that much
scientists have gone really good
at measuring tiny amounts of stuff
Bobby: how do you think they get
this blue color in the body wash?
well it's with blue 1 and
red 33 artificial coloring
but those are almost always
derived from tar or petroleum
loaded with toxins
and many of these colorants are
banned in other countries but not here
this is really silly more than usual
just because something comes from something
scary doesn't mean it's loaded with toxins
when they're making it they
get rid of these toxins
I mean he's just been groping all these plastic
bottles which are also made from petroleum
plus the US is actually really
strict with colorants they're
stricter than pretty much anywhere else
so the FDA in the US actually certifies each
batch of colorants and this is from their website
"the FDA determines the need
for batch certification based
on whether the color additives needs this
level of control to protect public health
some color additives in their uncertified
forms might contain impurities at levels
that pose a health concern and
colors subject to certification
are typically synthetic made from raw
materials obtained from petroleum"
so literally the FDA is really strict about
these supposed toxins that he's worried about
so someone from the FDA will
actually analyze the sample
they'll look at lots of things including purity
and they're specifically saying they
look for I'm reactive intermediates
colored impurities residual salts any other
unspecified impurities including heavy metals
if the sample doesn't meet these
requirements they reject the batch
and the FDA certifies color
additives before they're used
in products so it's illegal to
use colors that aren't certified
and yeah this is a really
high level of control higher
than these other countries he's talking about
Bobby: ph balanced for a woman but
strong enough for a man but also with
talc you don't want talc because talc
and asbestos go hand in hand which is
why baby powder isn't made with talc
anymore because you can't get rid of
the asbestos you gotta put it back even
though it's pH balance for me and you
*dramatic music*
ah Bobby it's so dramatic
I've talked about talc in asbestos before
I'll link the video down below but basically
from the evidence so far it is not that
big of a problem as is made out to be
you can actually see here the ewg only rates it
as a five which I'm actually kind of surprised
by it could be that there are a lot of organic
brands who use it there have been instances in
the past where the ewg will just like jiggle
their ratings ALLEGEDLY for their Partners,
their Partners pay a fee to be listed
nicely in their database ALLEGEDLY
one thing I will say for Bobby
is that his shirts are great
Bobby: the cosmetics industry is
not regulated nearly as much as the
food industry which is really scary
because this stuff goes on your body
so the question is what's the best
sunscreen as the summer comes upon us?
first off stuff that goes on your
body is generally less scary than
stuff that goes in your body because
yeah your skin does act as a barrier
sunscreen is a drug not a cosmetic in
the US which is where he is so he's
talking about entirely the wrong category here
Bobby: well there's two kinds of sunscreen there's
a mineral based the good ones
and chemical based the bad ones
minerals are often made of zinc oxide and that's
good because it never penetrates your skin
the chemical based ones are made with chemicals
that penetrate your skin and can be found in
your body in your breast tissue in baby milk
breast milk up to three or four weeks later
so minerals can penetrate your skin
especially if they have small enough particles
that's actually
why a lot of places have a different safety
assessment specifically for nanoparticles
I feel like I could just post myself
saying this to TikTok like every
week but the amount with normal use
doesn't seem to be a big health risk
because that is like the basis for all
of these safety assessments and that
is pretty much the same situation
for chemical sunscreens although
obviously for different substances
it will be different percentages
you have a huge range within chemical
sunscreens as well because a lot of
the new ingredients were specifically
designed to not get through skin easily
there were these studies on sunscreens
done by the FDA a while ago which was
all publicized as "sunscreens
get all the way into your blood"
this is not new information but the
nice thing about the FDA studies is
that they said how much actually gets in there
if you do a bunch of rough calculations you'll see
that only a fraction of a percent of most
of these chemical sunscreens get absorbed
also if you're wondering the safety assessments
do take into account developing fetuses usually
that is the endpoint that they're based on
I talked about that in my EU sunscreen video
so this whole good ingredient bad ingredient thing
really makes me cringe because
it is just such a big red flag
good and bad depends entirely
on dose and specifically in
sunscreen zinc oxide does have tons of
downsides which I've talked about before
the main one is that it is not very
good as a sunscreen you need lots
of it to absorb a relatively small amount of UV
people also underapply it because it's got a white
cast and it usually has a thick sticky texture
most people are probably at higher risk from
skin cancer than any hormonal
disruptions from a sunscreen
it's also not that great for the
environment despite what everyone
seems to be assuming I'll probably
make a video on that later too
Bobby: when you pick up a chemical
based one you're always going to
see the same active ingredients
avobenzone homosalate octisalate
these are the kind of chemicals
you want to avoid and if you're
ever thinking about using any kind of spray
spray bottle like this avoid it because when
it goes into the air it can be inhaled into
your lungs and coat the inside of your body
if you want to see a video about the best mineral
based sunscreens let me know and
I'll make a part two of the video
this is so weird like he says coat the inside
of your body like you don't
have stuff inside your body
with spray sunscreens I personally don't really
like them because there are a lot of downsides
the point that he made about how you
could inhale it is actually a good point
the health risk from inhaling sunscreen
is generally quite low it's taken into
account in the safety assessments but
the risk is higher for mineral sunscreens
but I think it's still not a very nice
experience to breathe it all in and you
end up with lower protection because your
insides do not need protection from the sun
alright that is enough Bobby for me today
he mostly makes food content
so if you want to see people
debunking that I highly recommend
@foodsciencebabe she is a legend
I'm pretty sure her eye rolling muscles must
be super buff because that has made me tired
@hormonespecialist: our next
estrogenic is sunscreens
I don't know of any sunscreen
with a chemical UV filter in it
that doesn't have some affinity for
hormonal receptors in the human body
some of the common ones are benzophenone
three or bp3 benzylidine camphor 3 BC
4-methylbenzylidine camphor or 4
MBC but there are dozens of them
watch out for the root benz or
phen in the chemical name better
yet just don't use a chemical based sunscreen
all right this one is a bit
more complicated because he
does talk about a lot of technical stuff
he's a pharmacist and he mostly runs a business
advising people on how to fix their hormones
my PhD is in medicinal chemistry I
also did pharmacology in undergrad
so receptors are like one of my
things you know my buddy old pals
so he says sunscreens all have affinity for
hormone receptors and yeah that is probably
true and not that surprising because lots of
substances will bind to receptors in our bodies
but the issue is that that alone
just doesn't tell you very much
so first off binding which just means
the sunscreen molecule comes along
and sticks to a hormone receptor inside your body
that doesn't just mean a negative effect
because how well something binds how sticky
it is that doesn't necessarily have a good
relationship with what it actually does there
obviously it has to stick to do something
but what it does there is a huge range
things that bind to the same receptor can have
completely opposite effects or even no effect
one more common example is with
opioid receptors which is where
opioids like fentanyl and heroin will act
both of those will have affinity for the receptor
so in other words they will stick to it but they
also have efficacy which means they will
actually trigger some sort of effect there
you might have heard of Narcan or
naloxone which is used to treat
opioid overdoses and the way that
that works is also by binding to the
same receptors but actually they have
more affinity they stick more strongly
but it doesn't actually trigger anything there
so it's got really really low or no efficacy
so it essentially kicks out the heroin or
fentanyl or whatever the person's overdosing on
it's a bit like a key and a lock so both heroin
and fentanyl can open this particular lock but
naloxone is sort of like a key that fits
in the lock but it doesn't open the door
and it actually gets stuck there and so it
blocks keys that will actually do something
and on top of that binding affinity is
about what happens when your sunscreen
and the receptor actually meet but the substance
actually has to get to the receptor
in a high enough concentration first
and where that receptor is in your body can mean
that binding there will trigger different effects
so this all sounds really scary because it's
unfamiliar and technical but
it doesn't really mean much
sunscreens still need to be assessed
for safety on a case-by-case basis and
that is actually what happens
for sunscreens to get approved
and that goes for both chemical
sunscreens and physical sunscreens
chemical sunscreens are lipophilic meaning
they're attracted to fat and we all have a
fatty layer in our skin so a lot of it absorbs
right in it doesn't just stay on the surface
remember the skin's an effective dosing route
for hormones and drugs applied as creams
so yes it acts as a barrier and protection
from exposures to lots of different things but
to substances with the right properties your
skin is like a wide open unguarded back door
and what goes in through the skin
dumps right into the bloodstream
without being metabolized at all
by the liver like food and other
things we eat which go to the liver
first and then into the circulation
it's like getting these chemicals by injection
yikes
so here is another bunch of arguments that
aren't quite right but they do have some grain
of truth and they sound complicated and scary
enough that people aren't going to question him
so let's break down all of this stuff
first off sunscreens are lipophilic
that means they're oil loving
the thing is though things that are too lipophilic
they don't actually get through skin easily
he makes it sound like the fatty layer
under the dermis which is the hypodermis
it's like there somewhere
it makes it sound like that is like
a magnet that just sucks lipophilic
things like chemical sunscreens through the skin
but the way that lipophilic oil loving
things stick to fat oil is through
forces called dispersion forces
and these are really short range
they don't act like a magnet they
can't suck things through the skin
essentially the chemical sunscreen has to
bump into the fat or oil before it sticks
like I think we all know that if
you rub coconut oil or just like
a greasy sunscreen on your skin
it doesn't all get sucked through
you can't feed yourself by rubbing coconut oil on
he is correct though that some substances can
get through skin really easily if they have
the right properties but that is not many
things and that is not chemical sunscreens
there are a lot of medications that
are meant to get into the bloodstream
and spread that way but so few
of them are delivered as creams
if injections and creams did the same
thing we just would never inject things
injections are so much more annoying and painful
if we could get them through easily without
injections then yeah that would be amazing
so things that do go through skin
easily they actually have to have
the right balance of lipophilic and hydrophilic
things that are very lipophilic like he says
they don't get through easily
skin has both water and oil
so you can see on my handy skin model
we have the blood here and to get to
the blood stuff has to go through a bunch of
different layers and these layers are complex
there are oily layers the top layer for
example is oily that's the stratum corneum
it has that brick and mortar structure
and the mortar between the bricks is
very oily and then you also have more
watery areas as well as you go down
so if a particular chemical is too
lipophilic it likes oil too much or
is too hydrophilic it likes water too much
it gets stuck on its way to the bloodstream
chemical sunscreens are quite lipophilic
so most of them actually get stuck in
this top layer of the stratum corneum
that's actually how chemical sunscreens
sink in a bit and they last for
longer than physical sunscreens
so to get into the blood it's not
just about being lipophilic it's
got to be the right balance of not
too lipophilic not too hydrophilic
and we do have data on how much
chemical sunscreens absorb into
blood and for most of these
it is a fraction of a percent
like I said before working out how much
of a chemical is likely to absorb into
blood is part of that toxicological
assessment that's done for sunscreens
he also didn't seem to realize
that the sccs has gone through
the data on benzophenone-3 which
is oxybenzone as well as 4-MBC
I mentioned before that they were only
looking at potential endocrine disruptors
and only a few sunscreens actually
made it to the list so only a handful
of chemical sunscreens have enough
evidence that it's worth reassessing
for the ones they have assessed they found that
there isn't enough evidence to say any of them
are endocrine disruptors except perhaps
4-MBC check out my video for more on that
so the reason that they've ended up at
a different conclusion from him is that
he is just looking at studies
and taking them at face value
he's assuming what happens in the study is exactly
the same as what happens when
we apply sunscreen on our skin
but studies in the literature generally aren't
done under realistic conditions so a lot of the
time it's animal and cell line studies which
they're obviously not the same as humans
even with human studies they usually use really
artificial conditions like
using way too much sunscreen
in the proper assessments like the ones done
by the sccs they translate the study so that
they're actually relevant to how normal
people use sunscreens and that's how they
come up with the guidelines that formulators
follow when they're making the sunscreens
it is all based on the same evidence it's just
that toxicologists are interpreting the studies
in a nuanced and scientific way whereas other
people are just not actually doing interpretation
Hormonespecialist: you may say well I don't often
use sunscreen so this really isn't an issue for me
but remember it's in cosmetics too
like makeup skin creams even some soaps
so daily application's a
likelihood for a lot of people
now chemical UV filters are required
to be listed as an ingredient in
cosmetic products but protecting
human skin is not their only use
they also protect other materials from the harmful
effects of UV light like plastics carpet furniture
and all of this is taken into
account in toxicological assessments
it really drives me off the wall when
people say but it adds up like it's
some sort of huge revelation it is not
a huge revelation it is really obvious
everyone from the age of I
don't know 20 maximum onwards
we know that we use more than one product
toxicologists do this every day as part of
their jobs they would have thought of this
I've been thinking about this for a pretty long
time and I'm probably going to do a video on it
it is actually quite depressing and
disturbing how much misinformation
is spreading and how social media
algorithms are really boosting it
it is just so much faster to scan ingredients
with some BS app and make a TikTok about how
scared you should be than to actually
work out the reality of what's going
on and figure out how to explain it
in a way that people can understand
there are also just so many more people who can
make this easy misinformation than people who
have the knowledge to debunk all of their claims
so there's just more BS content to begin with
and then there's a social media algorithm
part if you know anything about social
media marketing you'll know that
these algorithms generally reward
one capturing people's attention
in a really short time span and
two engagement
it is so much faster to explain some simplified
BS concept than complex messy science
and this sort of fear-mongering is such an
engagement magnet because we're
humans we care about other people
if we find out that something
common is dangerous we're going
to share it with people we care
about we are mostly good people
so these sorts of videos just
get pushed by algorithms as
everyone shares it and tags it and it
is just this massive compounding effect
so knowing this I think there are
some things that we can do to fight it
first off be careful before sharing videos
if it's something scary that is a massive red flag
if it talks about babies or pregnancy or cancer
if it's someone unqualified it's also a red flag
and yes sometimes unqualified
people can share scary things
that are true but these are just signs that
you should switch on your critical thinking
I think it's also good to do a reality check
large companies have hundreds
thousands of scientists
if some unqualified person can quickly work out
that they're all making toxic products there's
like zero chance that all of these scientists
have missed it or that they're all covering it up
big conspiracies involving hundreds of people just
do not work because people
do not keep their mouth shut
if you want to work out what's actually true
my advice is to look for the
consensus of relevant experts
you want to check with experts from multiple
relevant fields see what they mostly seem to
be saying and that is likely going to
be true or at least it won't hurt you
sometimes it can be hard to work out who
the relevant experts are and
which expert would know more
so for example if you remember
the benzene and sunscreen thing
when that first came out journalists seemed
to assume that dermatologists know
tons about benzene for some reason
but clearly most dermatologists
haven't even seen benzene in their life
the most relevant experts are
toxicologists and they were
saying something completely
different from dermatologists
and even within toxicology it is a really
diverse field so a toxicologist who does
academic research on frogs in the US might
not know anything about cosmetics in the EU
and there are malicious experts
out there who can be paid off
and also just incompetent people in every field
and that's why the consensus part is important
if a bunch of relevant experts
overwhelmingly say the same thing
it is probably what's going to be
true based on the current evidence
I hope that's useful
I'm sorry to be such a Debbie Downer
but this stuff is like a flood
tag me on TikTok and Instagram if you see any
posts that need debunking and
of course follow me on there
if you enjoyed this video click the like and the
subscribe to teach the algorithm
that this is what you like seeing
leave any myths you want me to debunk
in the comments I'll see you next time
and until then don't film supermarket lectures